-One of the many things
that broke my heart
about David Ortiz's retirement,
being a Red Sox fan,
is it was one
of my all-time favorite
"Weekend Update" characters
of yours.
-Yeah. Thank you.
-So, for you to lose
a great sports impression --
I was so happy last Thursday
on the "Weekend Updates"
to see you play LaVar Ball.
-I mean, thank God
for the world, you know.
The world just keeps...
-Yeah.
The world gave you LaVar Ball.
There you are.
-...giving us these characters.
[ Laughter and applause ]
You know?
-Yeah.
-What can you say?
-The guy, you know, he --
-And it's -- He's just --
-He loves his kids.
And he's pure ego.
It's so funny.
-A thousand percent.
-Yeah.
-He has enough ego
for all 17 kids.
-And what did -- what did he say
was in the shoes?
-They're made out of
South African
"rhino-soceros" horn.
[ Laughter ]
Pure rhino-soceros.
-The great thing
about watching it was,
when you said "rhino-soceros,"
I immediately
wanted you to say it
like 10 more times
in the sketch.
-Yeah. For sure. I wish
we could have built it in.
-And I think
you came pretty close.
-I mean, I was lucky
for it to get on, in my opinion,
because they had such a great
lineup with the Trump boys
and then Bill calling in
and Leslie and all them, too.
So I didn't really know if
it was going to make it or not.
And then they told us, like,
"All the features are in."
I was like,
"Okay, I got to go kill this."
-So even 15 years in, you're
still backstage saying like,
"Oh, am I gonna be
in the show or not?"
-Oh, I mean nothing.
-Yeah.
-I mean absolutely nothing.
[ Light laughter ]
15 years -- it doesn't matter,
because, like,
it's all about, you know,
a live show for that week --
you know what I mean?
-Do you, at least now,
15 years in --
had it not been in,
would you have been crushed,
or would you have just said,
"Oh, that's okay"?
-No, I was ready
for it not to be in.
I was surprised that it went in.
We would have maybe tried it
the next week
or wait
till the show comes around.
I mean, 568 shows today for you.
My God.
-Yeah. That's crazy.
-You know what I mean?
-Yeah, it's not that bad.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-So, I mean...
-Yeah.
-"SNL" because, you know,
it is such a protected place,
is very similar to that,
because we always know
there's another show coming,
another opportunity.
-Yeah. And you have a sense
LaVar Ball
is gonna stay in the news.
-I think so.
-Yeah.
-Yeah. I feel like
he likes it a little bit.
-[ Chuckling ] Yeah.
-Yeah.
-Well, that was the interesting
thing about Scaramucci
was there was a one-week window
to do a Scaramucci.
-Ohh.
-And now it's already --
I'm glad Bill did it,
but I don't think Bill's gonna
be dining out on Scaramucci.
-Yeah, it's not even fair, man.
-Yeah.
-It was, like, you know,
a fillet left behind.
-Yeah. It was like he --
-8-ounce butterflied fillet.
Sit there,
because I'm not feeling --
I'm not feeling steak tonight.
-Sir,
if you don't eat this soon,
there's gonna be flies
all over it.
-It -- It's okay.
I'll just pay and leave it.
[ Laughter ]
It's sad.
-You went to --
Dave Chappelle's doing a series
of shows at Radio City.
-Yes.
-And you went on Saturday,
and a lot of our --
our "SNL" friends were there.
-Oh, it was an --
it was an amazing night
because, number one, the homies
were, like, opening for him.
-Yeah.
-So Pete went out first.
-Pete Davidson.
-He crushed it. Yeah.
And then Colin went out --
Colin Jost -- for everyone.
[ Light laughter ]
And he did his thing.
And then Che went out --
Michael Che...
-[ Laughs ] Yeah.
-...like a -- like a rock star,
because, you know,
he's New York, home grown, so
they -- they really gave it up.
And then Leslie came out and
just, like, tore the roof off.
-Yeah. There are no --
-And...
-Leslie is currently leaving
no roofs on buildings.
-No.
-Yeah.
-It was just --
It was just funny
to hear the people around me,
like, "Yes! Work, Leslie, work!"
[ Laughter ]
It was like, "Oh, yeah.
We see
who's in the house tonight."
And then they reset for like
15 minutes or 20 minutes.
And you're -- you're thinking
that it's just like
the typical comedy show
or comedy evening or whatever.
And then Dave Chappelle
just came out
like a freaking rock star.
-Wow. That's amazing.
-Like, from out of the floor,
like, the smoke, the lights,
the old-school, like, arch
of lights and all of that.
-Have you ever
come out of a floor?
I'm realizing
I've never come out of a floor.
-It's --
You know, my own personal,
but nobody's been there
to watch.
[ Laughter ]
I actually do it every morning.
That's how I get up, and I
present myself to my house.
[ Laughter ]
But he just came out like a star
and then immediately started,
like,
tearing Trump's butthole out.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-It was -- It was awesome.
-Well, he's -- it's been
interesting to read about it...
-It was awesome.
-...because...
-It was that -- It was that day.
-Yeah.
-It was that day that all that
Charlotte stuff was going on.
And then, you know, of course
he felt, like, the burden --
because when he was on "SNL"
and he hosted last,
like, it was right after
Trump got elected.
-Yeah, that week.
-Like,
"America, give him a chance."
And he was, like,
"Man, 'f' that!"
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-I was like,
"Yeah, man, I feel you."
It's -- It's crazy times.
-Well, I'm so excited
for next Thursday.
I'm so excited
for the season premiere.
-Yeah, man, it's going down.
-And such a pleasure to have you
here, as always, buddy.
-Thank you, as usual.
-Kenan Thompson, everybody.